But, instead, we believe in looking at the
productivity of your company as a whole and
seeing what we can do to help.
Now, one area that we've noticed is a growing
productivity problem for a lot of you out
there is managing all of the applications
of your company.
Companies grow, engineering teams change,
servers move.
As all of that happens, it becomes increasingly
difficult to manage all of the applications
at your company.
As your company grows from having a few Internet
apps to having hundreds, and from ten employees
to thousands, managing that whole ecosystem
and keeping it healthy becomes an increasingly
large challenge for you.
So at Google, we thought about this problem.
And we wanted to do something to help.
Of course, since it has to do with hosting,
we looked to Google App Engine, Google's hosting
offering, which already serves over 100,000
applications that are used every single week.
But as we try to use App Engine to help with
enterprise software, we noticed that there
were some challenges to getting started.
As Google moved over its own I.T. infrastructure
to App Engine and as we talked to our employees,
our customers, and VMWare, it became increasingly
clear to us that the public cloud in general,
and Google's cloud in particular had some
barriers to writing enterprise software.
We heard that you needed something that was
more reliable.
We heard that you needed something that came
with support.
We heard you needed something with key features
that your enterprise can't live without.
We heard that you needed a better way to manage
all of these applications in the cloud, and
a way that would seem like the best possible
solution both to the engineers at your company,
as well as the I.T. administrators.
And, finally, we thought that you needed a
better way to pay for all of this.
Having a single engineering team sign up with
a credit card each time you want to create
an app, it's not a very scalable solution.
So we took these problems to heart, and over
the past year, we made investments to try
to fix these problems.
And thus, today's, I'm really excited to announce
to you a new product, Google App Engine for
Business.
Google App Engine for Business represents
a new version of App Engine that was built
from the ground up around solving the real
problems that enterprises face.
It's composed of five features that we believe
any business needs to build its infrastructure
on App Engine.
Those features are, one, a new company-centric
management console which makes it easy for
you to see, manage, and set security policies
across all of the applications in your domain.
Two, it comes with professional support so
that when it's crunch time and you need help
with your application, you know that there's
someone out there that you can reach.
It also comes with a formal service-level
agreement, or SLA, for the first time with
App Engine.
That means we're putting our money where our
mouth is when it comes to the reliability
of your business.
And, finally, it also comes with two additional
key features that we had heard almost every
enterprise needs: SSL for your company's domain,
and SQL databases.
That's right.
[ Applause ]
>>Kevin Gibbs: You heard me right.
When Google App Engine for Business is completely
available, you'll have the choice of using
our scalable data store, which is built on
Bigtable, or a standard SQL database.
We know that these features are critical to
enterprise adoption.
And, finally, Google App Engine for Business
also comes with a new way to pay for App Engine,
a new pricing model that's based around something
that's simple, your applications and your
users.
But, you know, I actually think the greatest
thing about Google App Engine for Business
is that it's based on the success that we've
already had with Google App Engine, a product
that's over a half a billion daily page views
strong and still growing.
It comes with all of the features that you
already know and love about Google App Engine:
Its standard Python and Java programming environments;
that it's easy to use and easy to scale, including
that it's free to get started.
With Google App Engine for Business, anyone
in your company can create an application,
develop it and test it, all for free.
When they're ready to share it with their
whole company, they just press "publish."
Now, I mentioned to you that Google App Engine
for Business comes with a new pricing model.
We had heard that our current pricing model
for App Engine is fairly complex, especially
for the enterprise use case.
So we wanted to do something simple.
We took a note from Google Apps for your domain.
The pricing for Google App Engine for Business
is really easy to understand.
Your applications cost $8 per user, up to
a maximum of $1,000 per application per month.
That's it.
There are no other fees or charges for you
to understand.
If you use your application within your domain,
your usage is unlimited and you can create
as many applications as you'd like.
That means with App Engine for Business, you
don't have to worry about the cost of your
data center, the cost of your management console,
the cost of your licenses and usage, all of
those things.
It's one simple price.
You know, we talked to a lot of CIOs when
we were working on this.
And we heard from many of you were spending
60% of your enterprise I.T. budget just keeping
the lights on.
Well, with Google App Engine for Business,
we think we can get that down to zero.
And we're putting our money where our mouth
is.
If your application in App Engine for Business
has no usage, you don't pay a dime.
Now, that's been a lot of me talking about
this new product.
I'd like to now actually show it to you.
I'd like to show you how the management console
in Google App Engine for Business makes it
easier for you to scale your company in terms
of the number of applications that you have
from the point of view of an engineer, an
I.T. admin, and a CIO.
So let me get started.
Bruce, I might need your help to log in here.
Thanks, Bruce.
All right.
So let me go ahead and open it up.
I'm going to open the management console for
App Engine for Business.
Now, for the purposes of this demo, we've
created an example company, The Surly Butcher
Corporation.
So I'm going to go ahead and log in as a developer
there.
Now, if you've used App Engine before, this
screen should be familiar.
It's our normal list of the applications that
you work on as an engineer at the company.
But as you go to create an application, you'll
notice there are a few things that are different.
One, you'll find that it's easier to find
an application identifier for the apps that
you want to create because these application
identifiers are limited to being within your
business.
So you no longer have to hunt around for one
in the global name space across Google.
You'll also notice that we've got a little
-- a different host name listed here, rather
than appspot.com.
When you create an application on Google App
Engine for Business, it's automatically mapped
into your company's domain.
You don't have to do any DNS setup or do any
virtual host or anything like that.
It just works with your company's domain name
and brand.
Now, I'm going to step back here for a second,
and I'm going to go to an application that
I deployed this morning, which is a sample
blog for The Surly Butcher Company.
So I'm going to open that up for you.
But before I do, I'm going to go in the background,
and I'm going to go log out of App Engine.
So I should be logged out now.
Now I'm going to go ahead and open up the
blog.
There we go.
And you can see it asked me to log back in.
That's because Google App Engine for Business
has security default.
They are set by the domain administrator,
and developers can't change them without permission.
That means that you can be sure your Internet
apps are safe.
So let me go ahead and log into the simple
app.
So there we go.
There's the company's simple blog.
You can see it's hosted on the company's domain
name, and I didn't have to set anything up.
So I'm going to go back to the application
view within the admin console.
Now, as I said before, this view should be
familiar to you.
This is the standard view you see in App Engine.
It will be the apps you work on.
But because this is a company, you'll notice
there's a new link up here which gives me
a link to all of the applications for this
company.
As I click on that, I can now see every application
that has been created within my company.
And for each application, I can see the applications
that I have access to and the ones that I
don't.
This helps your developers collaborate across
your company.
Now, one application that I work on inside
this company is the TechStop application.
This is one we use for our I.T. help desk
for the company.
When I open up this application, though, you'll
see the familiar dashboard.
But you'll notice there's a new tab under
"permissions."
With App Engine for Business, you can control
who has access to which application and what
level of access they have.
Now, for this application, you can see I'm
listed as a developer.
And that means that I have pretty much full
rights.
I can view the logs of this application.
I can go and deploy a new version of the application.
And I can go into the data store viewer for
the app and create new data or change data.
But if I go back to a list of applications,
I can see that there are some apps that I
don't have all the same level of privileges.
So if I open up our company's code review
application where we audit the code that we
work on, I can see that for this application,
I'm only listed as a viewer.
That means I can get to this dashboard and
view logs, but if I go to the data store viewer,
I can't change any data in the app and I can't
deploy a new version.
So this helps you manage within your company
and manage the data that you're working on
and the safety permissions with your company.
Now, if I jump back to the list of applications,
you'll see that there are some that I have
no access to at all.
These applications are ones that I'm just
not a developer on.
And if I click on one, you'll see I have no
access.
I can request access, though.
And I'll e-mail the developers to let me on
if I can.
Now, I said I was going to show you one other
thing.
And that was showing you that -- how a domain
administrator or CIO looks at all of this.
So I'm going to sign out quickly.
And I'm going to sign back in as someone who
is a domain administrator at this company.
So let me do that.
Now, as a domain administrator, I don't actually
have any applications, 'cause I don't write
code anymore.
But when I go to a list of all of the applications
for the company, you can see I have full access
to all of them.
And that means I can go to any app, grant
developer access or remove a developer who
has left the company and handle situations
like that.
So that's the demo of App Engine for Business.
Now I want to make one thing clear: Google
App Engine for Business represents a major
new effort from Google.
It's a big new thing that we're doing.
Today, I'm announcing App Engine for Business.
It's not yet entirely available for everyone
to use, but we know that enterprise development
schedules take time and that you need time
to plan.
Thus, we wanted to tell you about this as
soon as we could.
So in response to that, today, we're publishing
the road map for Google App Engine for Business.
Because some of the features I told you about
today will take longer than others, some will
be available sooner than others.
Our road map which is published online at
code.google.com, gives you an idea of when
each of these features will be available and
when you can expect to see it.
Already, a number of companies that we're
working with are already testing the App Engine
management console and using it to help manage
their company and all of the applications
within it.
So, that's the end of my talk today.
What I've shown you is a new version of App
Engine which is suited to business needs and
a new way to manage all of your applications
in the cloud.
So thank you for your time.
Please keep watching our road map to see how
we're doing.
And if you'd like to learn more about our
toughest customer of Google App Engine for
Business, please come see these talks where
you can see how Google itself is building
its I.T. apps on App Engine.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>David Glazer: Thanks, Kevin.
Thank you, Kevin.
Thank you, everyone.
Three more slides.
What did we show you?
We made four promises at the beginning.
We said we were going to show you how to build
apps faster with familiar technology, showed
you how integrating Spring tools in Google
Web Toolkit let that happen.
We said we were going to show you how to reach
all your user on all their devices.
The new mobile-ready widgets in Google Web
Toolkit make that happen.
We said we were going to show you how to stop
being trapped into an architecture by a choice
you make when you write your code.
The cloud portability solution we showed you,
working on VMWare on open standards made that
happen.
And we said we were going to show you how
to juggle a thousand applications for your
company and keep your sanity.
App Engine for Business allows that to happen.
If you want to learn more, attend the sessions,
you can go online at cloudportability at either
google.com or VMWare.com, get a lot more information,
pointers to documentation, downloads the tools,
access the road map, sign up for early use,
all of that.
We started this morning by talking about the
power of open standards and how open standards
leads to innovation.
Some of the people who started using the tools
that we showed you today, some of the people
who started using Spring several years ago,
started using Google Web Toolkit two years
ago, you're in this room.
When you started using those tools, you didn't
know that you were building applications that
were ready to run on Chrome.
You didn't know that you were running applications
that were ready to run on the Android browser.
You didn't know that you were building for
the platform of the future, because it didn't
exist when you started building your apps.
But because you chose to invest in open standards,
you chose to innovate in the open, you are
ready for the future.
Stay with the open standards.
Stay with the Web.
Stay with HTML5.
Come with us into the future.
We're excited about it.
We know you're excited.
Enjoy the sessions.
Enjoy the rest of your two days here.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]